[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue dans sensublic
l'émission qui donne du sens à
l'actualité et qui se met au service des
citoyens nous sommes le jeudi 4 mai et
nous sommes ensemble pour 1h30 de débat
et de décryptage alors c'était il y a un
an au lendemain de la présidentielle
insoumise socialiste communiste
écologiste décidé d’unir leurs forces
derrière une bannière commune celle de
la nouvelle union populaire écologiste
et sociale mais alors de souffler la
première bougie c'est un peu la soupe à
la grimace alors comment va la nupes
doit-elle s'ouvrir doit-elle évoluer et
puis comment peut-elle faire taire ces
petites guerres intestines ce sera le
sujet de notre premier débat d'actualité
politique dans la deuxième partie aussi
mais cette fois-ci en Turquie ou l'homme
fort d'Ankara Récept Taipe Erdogan
affronte une campagne présidentielle
compliquée et s'en prend très violemment
à son adversaire
si vous voulez prendre une leçon de
mensonge adressez-vous à son bureau
c'est un expert en la matière mais le 14
mai si Dieu le veut ma nation les fera
mourir politiquement
les élections présidentielles et
législatives du 14 mai mettrontelle un
terme à son règne autoritaire et alors
quelles conséquences pour les Turcs mais
aussi pour nous européens nous ferons le
point avec nos experts mais tout de
suite place à notre premier débat depuis
quelques jours c'est un peu le festival
des petites phrases entre les
partenaires de la nupes au moment où
elle fait son premier anniversaire on
voit au surgir des querelles de ligne
des querelles de personnes et on se
demande s'il y a du peste ce serait pas
en train de réinventer la gauche la plus
bête du monde on fait le point avec
Jérôme Rabier elle paraît loin cette
image d'unité de la gauche avec toutes
les têtes d'affiches ensemble sur les
Strad célébrons l'accord de la nu pour
les législatives et pourtant à la tout
juste un an une année pendant laquelle
il a fallu tenter d'avancer en évitant
les couacs un an après Jean-Luc
Mélenchon pas vraiment en retrait
demande un acte de cette alliance on va
commencer la phase 2 de l'existence de
cette alliance de cette une convergence
de ce front qui est la nubes de manière
à ce qu'aux prochaines élections
européennes et bien la nuit pèse
confirme qu'elle existe et qu'elle
pourra ensuite passer aux autres étapes
mardi soir une réunion au sommet s'est
tenue entre les représentants des
différentes composantes de la nuque et
cela à chauffer le communiste Fabien
Roussel qui avait déjà jugé l'accord
dépassé à évoquer un boulet une camisole
et la question des élections européennes
de l'an prochain ou seuls les insoumis
défend l'idée d'une liste commune en
venime les débats pour les vers qui font
leur meilleur score pas question de
partir groupées nous voulons une Europe
forte et fédérale on est peut-être pas
les seuls au monde à le vouloir tant
mieux il trouve que toute la famille
verte européenne est soudée là-dessus et
que dans tous les bulletins dans tous
les pays d'Europe il y aura un bulletin
vert pour défendre nos idées écologistes
au PS fracturé entre d'un côté les
partisans d'Olivier Faure et de l'autre
la ligne anti-up menée par Nicolas Mayer
rossignol impossible de trancher le
parti à la rose tente actuellement de
définir son projet et à temps pour la
suite nous aurons un débat de fond et à
ce moment là nous verrons ce qu'il en
est nous verrons ce qu'il est possible
de faire est-ce qu'une liste de la nuque
sera possible je ne le sais pas est-ce
que une liste autonome du Parti
socialiste sera présenté aux élections
européennes c'est une probabilité assez
grande aujourd'hui les socialistes
rappellent que la question européenne
est celle qui a historiquement fracturé
la gauche notamment lors du référendum
de 2005 une fracture qui avait été
déterminante dans le choix de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon de quitter le parti socialiste
à l'époque pas sûr que les prochaines
échéances permettent de recoller les
morceaux
alors ce drôle d'anniversaire de la
nupesse on en parle ce soir avec mes
invités bonsoir Frédéric savity vous
êtes professeur de sciences politiques à
l'université Panthéon Sorbonne à vos
côtés Virginie Martin bonsoir vous êtes
politologue chercheuse à la cage Bunny's
Business School pardon pierre Jacquemin
vous êtes rédacteur en chef de politique
je crois qu'on devrait voir d'ailleurs
la couverture du dernier numéro et puis
Mathilde Sirault notre éditorialiste qui
m'accompagnera tout au long de cette
émission première question
c'est un bon anniversaire ou pas on va
faire simple on peut choisir un mot
Fabien Roussel a donné un exemple boulet
camisole comment vous qualifier cette
cette nuit PS Virginie ce que je trouve
déjà important c'est que grâce à cette
formation depuis un an il y a quand même
des enjeux qui ont pris de la visibilité
et ça je trouve que c'est quand même
vraiment très important les questions
évidemment du féminisme de l'éco
féminisme de la croissance de l'écologie
bien entendu sur la question féministe
il y a un peu le quoique de évidemment
on peut pas ne pas y penser mais quand
même je trouve que il y a des choses qui
sont venues sur la table qui étaient
véritablement des choses très hommages
de la question politique et des enjeux
et je trouve que grâce à la nupesse et
tous ces enjeux sont revenus vraiment et
sont même arrivés à gagner l'effet d'un
jardin les faits médiatiques et ça c'est
quand même pas rien et je trouve aussi
par ailleurs que l'effet bannière ne
pèse a bien fonctionné maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière la bannière
c'est bien la question Frédéric savie
qui va bien elle va pas bien un bulletin
de santé par rapport à l'anniversaire
bah faut quand même se féliciter parce
que l'anniversaire c'est quand même 160
et quelques députés du pain c'est sans
l'accord bah probablement que ce groupe
enfin ces groupes aurait été beaucoup
plus restreint donc ça c'est quand même
un bilan positif du côté du négatif
c'est on le sait c'est un accord qui a
été quand même très rapidement négocié
aussi bien sur le plan programmatique du
partage on va dire des rapports de force
et aujourd'hui on voit bien que c'est ça
qui coince c'est à dire qu'il faudrait
se mettre de travail et évidemment
faire évoluer ce programme le faire
aussi partager par des militants des
différents partis politiques qui lors
des différents congrès qui ont eu lieu
depuis novembre ont montré que il y
avait pas mal de choses qui ne passaient
pas donc je dirais que du Pesse est un
processus
chaotique mais qui va quand même me
semble-t-il dans le bon sens parce que
ça correspond aussi à une forte attente
des électeurs les enquêtes d'opinion le
montrent il y a une aspiration quand
même à l'union de la gauche alors avec
évidemment un flou mais bon qui existe
pierre Jacquemin est-ce que comme on dit
au football le groupe va bien alors moi
je pense que précisément il va bien
c'est à dire qu'il y a un récit
médiatique qui a consisté à vouloir
faire croire qu'effectivement on avait
là un accord de gens de groupe de
parties qui étaient pas forcément le
plus cohérent du monde mais qu'est-ce
que la nups la nups c'est un
inter-groupe justement de députés qui se
réunissent régulièrement et cette
interview qui fait la partie qui qui est
parti intégrante de la nupesse
fonctionne plutôt bien pendant un an ils
ont travaillé ensemble on l'a très peu
on a très peu parlé justement de ce côté
laupestre mais vraiment c'est ça la nuit
pêche c'est que l'interview c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs la limite de la
nups moi je veux dire deux choses parce
que je trouve que ce qui est positif
dans ce qui s'est passé avec la nuit
pêche en tout cas le fait majeur de
cette nupes c'est que ça a ramené le
Parti socialiste à gauche et le parti de
la social-démocratique a été le parti
dominant au moins une par la deuxième la
première moitié du siècle précédent
revient aujourd'hui dans le dans le
monde politique comme étant un vrai
parti de gauche pendant longtemps le
Parti socialiste n'était pas accepté ni
acceptable dans les manifestations
aujourd'hui de partialisme Olivier fort
le premier est applaudi dans les
manifestations le deuxième fait marquant
c'est que ce que l'on a critiqué de la
part de la France insoumise qui est à
l'origine quand même de cette dynamique
qui a qui a lancé les discussions le
premier sont d'ailleurs forcément y
croire que c'était possible d'obtenir un
accord avec le Parti socialiste à un
tout petit peu mis son sa superbe en
tout cas ce sont cette tentation
hégémonique de côté et c'est ce qui est
aussi permis je pense l'alliance entre
ces parties aujourd'hui qu'on croyait
absolument irréconciliables hier
en un mot pour décrire le bulletin de
santé de laupes en fait tout dépend si
on résume ce qu'on met derrière de nups
si c'est un outil effectivement
parlementaire ça fonctionne plutôt si
par là on entend plus largement
ce qui a pu succéder au programme commun
il y a longtemps là c'est là où tout
reste à faire en fait parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses idéologiques
effectivement à régler et des choses à
consolider et bien sûr des questions de
personnes qui perdure et qui vont
continuer à hésiter alors pour
comprendre ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
il faut aussi revenir aux origines et
comprendre comment tout ça c'est
construit Frédéric saviecki qu'est-ce
qui explique le le succès la création et
le succès de la nups
c'est la décision on va dire de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon un rebours de ce qu'il avait
fait en 2017 de tendre la main on va
dire aux autres partis de gauche et de
façon très large puisque ça inclut
effectivement le Parti socialiste je me
souviens qu'à un moment il était
question par exemple d'intégrer le
nouveau
dans la coalition et quand la
possibilité d'intégrer le PS c'est
offert le NPA s'est retiré donc on voit
bien quand même que tout n'était pas
totalement joué c'était une vraie
surprise d'ailleurs c'est une vraie
surprise et ça attendait quand même déjà
à l'époque au sein du Parti socialiste
puisqu'elle m'a mis un recours devant
les tribunaux de quelques dirigeants
mécontents qui considèrent que les
militants n'avaient pas été correctement
consultés pour l'accord mais c'est passé
et puis derrière ça ça a marché si on
peut dire en termes de nombre de députés
donc ça ça là-dessus c'est c'est il faut
quand même rendre gré on pourrait dire à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon d'avoir au fond
accepter de partager les dépoux ici on
peut dire
ce qu'il avait pas fait par par le passé
alors le problème effectivement c'est
que
la dupesse paye quand même le fait
d'avoir été mis sur les portées sur les
fonds bâtissements par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et la France insoumise
c'est-à-dire que ça c'est quelque chose
le paye parce que d'abord dans l'opinion
c'est une peste est très associée à LFI
dans l'esprit de beaucoup de militants
écologistes socialistes etc la nupesse
est vue d'abord comme un instrument qui
a profité à Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a pu
ainsi apparaître finalement comme un
fédérateur de la gauche est-ce que
quelqu'un oui
mais sans doute le Parti communiste
n'aurait pas de groupe sans doute les
socialistes n'auraient pas de groupe
donc
ça a été le fédérateur de la gauche
ça a été le fédérateur de la gauche mais
en même temps sur une base c'est à dire
une base de rapport de force si on peut
dire qui est quand même très favorable à
LFI c'est-à-dire par rapport à
l'équilibre des des gauches par rapport
à l'état des rapports de force qui sont
issus de l'élection présidentielle c'est
pas trop mais en même temps on sait bien
que les forces écologistes sociales
démocrates dans ce pays représente plus
si on regarde notamment le résultat des
élections intermédiaires des élections
locales des élections régionales les
forces militantes aussi plus que le
score d'Anne Hidalgo le score de ou même
que le score de Yannick Jadot puisque
beaucoup de gens ont voté Mélenchon
d'électeurs de gauche ont voté leurs
champs aussi par parce qu'il était le
mieux placé pour éventuellement empêcher
à nouveau duel entre Marine Le Pen et
Emmanuel Macron donc
c'est ça qui à mon avis est un des
problèmes on va dire congénitaux de la
nupupette c'est je pense qu'il faudrait
accepter alors ça peut dire que elle est
si a commencé à le faire mais ça de
façon à remettre en partie les choses à
plat mais il faudrait sans doute aller
beaucoup plus loin puisqu'on voit bien
que sur les élections européennes
aujourd'hui etc etc mais voilà c'est
c'est ça à mon avis qui qui a un petit
peu le point de faiblesse Virginie
Martin il y a un vice de conception
origine de laupes disons que on dit
toujours finalement que grâce à tout ça
ça a beaucoup bénéficié à Europe
Écologie Les Verts européen au PC c'est
un peu toujours l'histoire dominante qui
est racontée mais ça a aussi beaucoup
bénéficié à LFI qui a quand même une
image édulcorée grâce à cela elle s'est
finalement un peu adoucie cette image à
les filles parce que quand même dans les
rang
aller voter pour quelqu'un sur les
circonscriptions qui avaient quand même
l'étiquette LFI même s'il y avait
évidemment la mieux pèse de vent ça a
été aussi très compliqué pour certains
socialistes aussi bah on le voit encore
plus aujourd'hui bien entendu et pour
certains communistes aussi de toute
façon on le voit aussi donc on voit que
ça tireille c'est vrai qu'il va y avoir
de toute façon un problème de leadership
c'est ce que vous disiez d'une certaine
manière il va y avoir ce problème de
leadership comment on tourne la page
quel présidentiable peut-il advenir pour
2027 on voit bien que Manuel Bompard
justement vraiment résiste à ce qu'il y
ait une parenthèse utile il n'en veut
pas de cette parenthèse des européennes
voir des sénatoriales aussi où il y a
des problèmes aussi pour cet automne
donc on voit bien que la LFI a vraiment
intérêt à ce que la nupestre continue
parce que sinon ils vont se retrouver
aux marges en définitive et un petit peu
esseulé et peut-être qu'il risque de le
payer beaucoup plus cher que les autres
contrairement à ce qu'on dit parce que
évidemment ils ont créé la dy mais dans
le même temps ça leur a permis d'avoir
une image un petit peu moins radicale et
toujours c'est toujours après ce qui
interroge sur la radicalité au-delà du
leadership mais ça va un peu ensemble
c'est quand Jean-Luc Mélenchon dit il
faut de la conflictualité voilà la
politique c'est la conflictualité voilà
exactement et ça c'est peut-être un peu
disait il y a 5 ans où il y a 10 ans il
leur dit comme ça ça m'attriste et c'est
quand même important et à la fois ça le
côté un peu radical ce que d'ailleurs
Clémentine Autain assume dans vos
colonnes pierre où elle dit en effet
c'est vers le du côté du radical qu'on
arrive et de la radicalité qu'on
arrivera à gagner et ça ce n'est pas sûr
je suis pas sûr Jacquemin
ça a été le martingale électorale d'une
certaine façon cette épée puisque c'est
vrai que ça permet de faire rentrer un
très grand nombre de députés et puis là
on sort d'un conflit sur les retraites
quatre mois de conflit 14 manifestations
et on a l'impression qu'il y a une forme
d'impasse politique pour la nupté
puisque la loi est passée la façon dont
ils se sont opposés n'a pas permis de
faire capoter le projet et puis parce
qu'en terme d'image quand on regarde les
sondages en tout cas il n'apparaissent
pas comme les grands gagnants c'est
Marine Le Pen c'est les syndicats et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou la lupet ça
paraissent loin loin très loin derrière
est-ce qu'ils sont plantés sur toute la
ligne
alors d'abord les jeux sont pas faits on
n'a pas fait on n'est pas encore au
prochain scrutin on sait pas ce que les
prochains scrutins donneront c'est pas
comment la nuit pèse va évoluer quels
seront les discours il faut se rappeler
quand même dans l'histoire que les
grandes victoires les ont été la gauche
a été victorieuse après des grandes
mobilisations mais vous prenez 36 il y a
eu avant 36 bien des mobilisations avant
que le Front populaire n'existe vous
prenez 97 il a fallu qu'il y ait 95 des
grandes mobilisations sociales il a fait
du 2 ans pour que la gauche reprenne le
revienne au pouvoir donc tout peut être
aller très vite la nuit Pesse on est un
exemple ce qu'on a oublié de dire c'est
que la nups née dans un contexte près
présidentiel ou la gauche c'est entre
tuer entre elles souvenez-vous les
discours dan Hidalgo contre Jean-Luc
Mélenchon l'accusant de complaisance
avec Poutine et bien d'autres encore
enfin c'était une violence sans nom donc
c'était presque impensable que cet
accord puisse se faire ça s'est fait
aussi parce que c'est une nouvelle
génération qui s'est retrouvée autour de
la table vous avez on a tous découvert
des nouveaux visages du côté de LFI du
côté du Parti socialiste du côté du
Parti communiste qui se sont retrouvés
avec des cultures des sensibilités
différentes et qui avait envie d'aboutir
parce que je trouve qu'il procès qui a
été un peu injuste qui a été fait au
sein de la France insoumise même si je
partage cette analyse qui consiste à
dire qu'il y a toujours cette tentation
hégémoniste où hégémonique du parti du
pas du Parti socialiste mais en tout cas
de la France insoumise
parce que c'est socialiste beaucoup
d'entrée d'entre eux du de la France
insoumise c'est son quand même beaucoup
des anciens socialisme moi j'ai toujours
dit que Jean-Luc Mélenchon était le
candidat de la social-démocratie en 2022
il était pour moi un pro il avait un
programme social-démocrate donc je dis
que le procès était un peu injuste parce
que c'est pour ça que je disais que
c'est pas tout à fait juste ce que vous
disiez Frédéric parce que ça ça
évidemment profité à la France insoumise
cette nuit pèse parce qu'il y a une
dynamique électorale mais ça a surtout
profité aux autres formations politiques
qui étaient quand même dans un état pas
possible c'est-à-dire que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon aurait pris la décision de
partir seul en campagne aux élections
législatives pas sûr qu'ils auraient eu
autant de députés mais en revanche le
Parti socialiste sans doute se retrouver
sans députés le Parti communiste sans
député et les écologistes qui n'en
avaient pas n'en aurait pas retrouvé
donc au moins à minima ça a été la
grande lucidité de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'était de considérer qu' effectivement
son discours passé ne pouvait plus tenir
si à un moment donné il voulait
reprendre le pouvoir et redevenir
majoritaire donc ce que je veux dire
c'est que par rapport à la question qui
était la vôtre c'est que la gauche sans
doute aujourd'hui peut-être fait du
surplace peut-être ne dire pas les
bénéfices du mobilisation ça vous étonne
pas d'abord encore une fois je vous
allez vous allez dire je fais un procès
aux médias mais je trouve que là aussi
sur la question de qui gagne la séquence
dire en permanence pas vous ici
particulièrement mais dire en permanence
c'est Marine Le Pen elle a été sage et
la plus c'est la plus belle républicaine
ce sont les sondages généralement qui
dit ça c'est pas les médias alors en
plus les questions
d'ici sur ce plateau pardon et de le
redire mais si vous prenez les sondages
en dehors des grandes individus aussi
vous faites pas un sondage uniquement
sur les personnalités que vous faites
sur les sondages de de législatives s'il
y avait des législatives anticipées ce
qui arrive en tête c'est la nups enfin
les sondages montrent que c'est la nuit
pêche qui arrive en tête des sondages
c'est pas de manière fulgurante elle
progresse pas de manière fulgurante mais
il faut arrêter de dire que Marine Le
Pen serait la grande vainqueur de cette
séquence il faut arrêter de dire qu'elle
serait la plus républicaine parce que la
France insoumise aurait eu trois totos
ou trois énervés qui ont fait des
conneries au sein de l'hémicycle
peut-être que peut-être que là-dessus la
grande interrogation est sondages ou pas
sondage je trouve que la question quand
même continue de se poser c'est comment
la nuit pèse ou tous ces groupes de
gauche bon essayez réussir ou pas à
récupérer l'électoratoires ouvriers
c'est quand même un vrai problème c'est
ça la question elle est là et finalement
aujourd'hui sondage ou pas sondage on
voit bien que de toute façon c'est le RN
qui prospère le plus et depuis
maintenant beaucoup d’années donc c'est
beaucoup plus structurel que
conjoncturel auprès des lectorat ouvrier
ça c'est vraiment un problème et on voit
bien d'ailleurs que Fabien Roussel
essaye comme il peut justement d'aller
un peu séduire électorat ouvrier avec
des vieilles recettes etc mais que tu
auras ouvriers n'est plus celui
évidemment aux années 70 tout ça à muté
et il s'est vraiment ancré très
profondément quand même du côté du RN
même si on sait aussi que les ouvriers
et là-dessus on est d'accord on peut on
peut mettre cette nuance alors je
voudrais quand même qu'on s'attarde
quelques minutes sur ces petites phrases
pas juste pour le plaisir des petites
phrases mais parce que pour savoir ce
que ça traduit depuis quelques jours je
le disais en introduit Antoine
introduction de cette émission on
assiste quand même à des pics partout
delier par exemple la plateforme des
écolos dimanche dans le Journal du
Dimanche estime que les insoumis lui
mettent une pression aussi désagréable
qui respectueuse pour les européennes
mépris mauvaise foi et sectarisme
irresponsable répond à la député Daniel
au Bono on peut rappeler que le stand du
Parti communiste a été attaqué pendant
la manif du 1er mai par des casseurs au
cri de tout le monde déteste Fabien
Roussel lui hier dit que la nupesse est
un boulet ou une camisole la semaine
dernière tiens pierre Jacquemin c'est
vous qui vous êtes pris une volée de
bois vert pour avoir fait discuter
ensemble
l'insoumise Clémentine Autain et
l'ancien Premier ministre socialiste
Bernard cazen pourquoi tant de haine
comment ça s'explique d'abord parce
qu'il y a un quinquennat qui a été celui
de François Hollande qui a laissé des
traces
presque un débile au sein de la gauche
François Hollande a trahi les lectorat
de gauche a trahi les partenaires qui
étaient les siens qui l'ont porté au
pouvoir pendant son quinquennat donc ce
qu'un canal de François Hollande reste
un traumatisme un grand traumatisme pour
une grande partie de l'électorat de
gauche et la raison pour laquelle
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est devenu Roussel
marine tondeuse n'était pas concerné par
ça comptable du du quinquennat de
François Hollande dans cette d'abord
parce que c'est encore récent que je
pense il est encore récent que le Parti
socialiste a fait un peu son inventeur
et sa critique du quinquennat de
François Hollande vous avez raison de
dire que Marine tondeuillier d'autres
n'étaient pas des acteurs politiques à
ce moment-là mais ça reste encore très
très fort très présente très prévenant
il y a il y a la théorie qui a été celle
de Manuel Valls des deux gauches
irréconciliables sur bien des questions
et je les dis tout à l'heure mais toutes
les questions de de de lier à
l'international notamment énormément
Clive et à gauche on a parlé de gauche
irrégonciliables parce que sur les
questions de laïcité sur les questions
de République il y avait pas de points
de convergence entre certaines visions
de monde opposé à gauche mais moi
l'absolu conviction qui est la mienne
compte tenu de ce qu'on a vu et de
l'année qui vient de s'écouler avec la
muppesse c'est qu'il y a quand même
beaucoup plus de choses qui rassemble
tous ces gens là que de choses qui
divisent après il faut prendre en compte
aussi un certain nombre de choses marine
tombe de nuit quand elle dit qu'elle
partira autonome aux européennes d'abord
elle a un mandat qui a été le sien qui
lui a été donné par les militants
écologistes qui étaient on va aux
européennes de manière autonome après il
y a l'ambition des autres celle de la
France insoumise qui dit si on veut
construire une alternative crédible
d'ici à 2027 il faut aussi qu'on montre
qu'on fasse à démonstration que dans une
élection comme les élections européennes
on est capable de se mettre d'accord et
de créer une dynamique et je pense qu'il
a raison là-dessus parce que si l'enjeu
c'est de batte Marine Le Pen est de date
Emmanuel Macron il faut bien faire la
démonstration que européenne ils sont en
capacité je viens les querelles de
personnes les attaques alors l'Union est
un combat disait un vieux communiste
directeur de l'humanité ne sont pas que
des querelles de personnes ce sont des
querelles aussi d'appareils ici on peut
dire c'est-à-dire qu'on a affaire à des
partis politiques le Parti communiste
les Verts les socialistes donc voilà
dans la préoccupation est quand même
aussi de de d'éviter de continuer à
au profit de la France insoumise
d'obtenir des des élus de rééquilibrer
le rapport de force parce que c'est ça
aussi qui va éventuellement fonder une
renégociation
ultérieure du nombre de circonscriptions
de la manière dont s'opérera ou pas la
désignation du candidat ou de la
candidate à l'élection présidentielle et
ce qui s'est exprimé lors des congrès
aussi bien des écologistes que des
socialistes et des communistes on a eu
trois congrès en quelques mois c'est une
espèce de prurit un peu identitaire les
militants ont repris la main et ils sont
dit non attendez il est pas question
qu'on se dissolve comme ça à n'importe
quel prix au profit d'un candidat bon
dont on sait pas très bien s'il sera
encore candidat Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
d'un parti qui n'est pas un parti c'est
à dire qu'il y a qui reste une
entreprise tournée vers l'élection
présidentielle qui a moins d'intérêt
évidemment sur les élections
intermédiaires et donc ça évidemment ça
ça produit un manquablement des
frottements
évidemment alors on parlait du
contentieux avec le Parti socialiste
mais on pourrait parler aussi du
contentieux entre LFI et les parties
communistes en 2000 en 2017 elle est si
a présenté beaucoup de candidats dans
des circonscriptions qui étaient
historiquement on va dire des lieux
d'implantation communiste à laisser des
traces évidemment très très fortes donc
tout ça évidemment remonte à la surface
et particulièrement remontée à la faveur
des congrès qui sont tenus donc les
dirigeants qu'est-ce qu'ils font bah ils
expriment la parole aussi de leur base
et quand Marine tondeuillier dit bah non
il y aura une liste écologiste parce que
c'est pas seulement un accord européen
mais c'est aussi ce que souhaite les
militants ben elle ne fait que dire ce
qu'attend évidemment c'est Mandans elle
peut pas dire autre chose donc parfois
ça dérape parce que la médiatisation
fait que certaines phrases peuvent être
en quelque sorte comme ça un peu un peu
excessive mais ça aussi un niveau de
virulence ou un niveau de violences
verbale qu'il y ait à la radicalité
aussi qui avait pas forcément avant
cette violence elle est assez
généralisée j'allais dire dans les modes
de communication contemporain on a fait
des on a détruites on a des informations
qui sont reprises en bande et pour se
faire entendre il faut évidemment
gérer accentuer la virulence du propos
bon voilà il y a une
malheureusement on peut le déplorer le
temps le temps de débat plus polissé
semble derrière nous mais
fondamentalement je dirais que ce qui
s'exprime derrière tout ça ce sont des
des luttes entre des organisations qui
ont des finalités très différentes voilà
et des problèmes de ligne aussi et en
même temps il y a pas qu'à gauche
oui on a évidemment pas la même vision
de l'Europe ou des relations
internationales c'est pas rien non non
c'est une histoire ce n'est pas rien
mais ça on voit bien que ces plastiques
c'est à dire pour les législatifs pour
la nuit pêche ça a cessé d'être un
problème pour les élections européennes
ça redevient un problème donc si vous
voulez c'est ce que dit marine tondeuse
dans la même interview pour finir de la
cité dans le JDD où elle explique il y a
des différends sur des sujets qui sont
loin d'être des détails elle donne des
exemples la Chine l'Ukraine l'Europe
c'est quand même pas rien non vous avez
raison mais vous prenez j'ai vu j'ai lu
avec beaucoup d'attention la présidente
du groupe LFI au Parlement européen mano
Aubry répondent point par point à Marine
Tondelier il y a quand même un peu de
allez de je dirais pas du cirque mais il
y a un peu d'hypocrisie aussi parfois
j'entends et vraiment je respecte le
choix de marine tondeuse de respecter le
la parole de ces militants je pense
aussi que la proposition qui a été celle
du Parti socialiste il y a quelques
jours dans le JDD de faire un grand une
grande mise dans l'espace public et tu
as fait état en tout cas des désaccords
ou des points de convergence sur la
question européenne entre septembre et
novembre me paraissent saine c'est à
dire qu'il faut un moment donné que la
gauche se mettre aussi d'accord sur des
procédés des procédés des processus qui
soit différent que des tweets interposés
ou des objectifs interposés et je trouve
que la proposition du Parti socialiste
qui a été acceptée d'ailleurs par la
France insoumise me paraît être la bonne
solution on va voir sur les européennes
si vraiment il y a un vrai désaccord
parce que les questions sémantiques les
Français s'en foutent je pense il y aura
rien à voir ils ont ils s'en fout de
savoir si on veut désobéir retraités ou
si on veut renégocier les traités etc je
pense que la stratégie à la fin en tout
cas l'objectif final de ce qu'on veut de
l'Union européenne de ce qu'ils veulent
de l'Union européenne et globalement
partagé la Chine des accusations qui ont
été celles du Parti socialiste sur la
complaisance de Jean-Luc Mélenchon avec
la Chine ou la Russie on l'a aussi je
pense que tout le monde a mis un peu
d'eau dans son vin et on était dans une
campagne présidentielle et qu'il fallait
cliver et abuser un peu de de certains
de certains discours donc moi je trouve
que c'est plutôt sain ce qui est proposé
aujourd'hui par la nups une partie de la
nupestre qui va être acceptée je pense
dans les prochaines semaines mettez mais
qui se mettent autour d'une table et qui
dit si oui ou non il y a la possibilité
d'un accord aux européennes c'est la
meilleure des stratégies le problème
c'est ce que vous disiez peut-être tout
à l'heure c'est un inter-groupe
parlementaire là du Pesse mais il y a
pas de structure il y a pas de collectif
il y a pas de lieu de délibération il y
a pas de congrès c'est toute
l'architecture qui manque Virginie ma
femme oui c'est vrai qu'il va falloir de
toute façon trouver une méthode pour
trouver des points de convergence ça
c'est évident mais après est-ce que
effectivement il y a des points de
convergence qui vont être trouvés de
manière durable parce on a mis un peu la
poussière sous le tapis en juin dernier
un petit peu quand même là par exemple
aujourd'hui typiquement manuel Bompard
se félicite parce que les soignants non
vaccinés sont réintégrés dans les
hôpitaux au même moment certains
Européens Écologie Les Verts disent
qu'est-ce que c'est cette posture anti
science-fictionnistes pour le vaccin
obligatoire voilà exactement
c'est pas juste des
postes à un moment donné qu'est-ce qui
va se dire effectivement sur la question
de l'Europe même sur la question
écologique sur la question du nucléaire
ça me paraît aussi important sur le
capitalisme l'économie de marché
l'anticapitalisme dit certains au
contraire là il y a vraiment des choses
qui sont qui vont au-delà de ces
fameuses gauches irréconciliables à la
Manuel Valls à l'époque là on a aussi
ouvert d'autres thématiques comme je
disais au début d'ailleurs et c'est
autre enjeux évidemment on leur lot
aussi de division de dissension et de
fragilité entre tous ces acteurs donc
c'est tout ça aussi est difficile c'est
pareil aussi sur la question alors c'est
pas forcément laïcité mais sur la
question culturellealiste
intersectionnalité qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec tout ça voilà ou gauche
universaliste je n'emplerai pas je vais
le dire sans le dire évidemment et
j'enlève ce mot immédiatement de mon
esprit tout ce qui est walkies
aujourd'hui qui est tellement tellement
à la mode et tellement dont les gens
s'en ont pas s'empare beaucoup mais
enfin derrière ça il y a quand même
aussi effectivement cette gauche dit
univers versus cette gauche plus
culturelleliste et plus
intersectionnaliste et en plus ça a pris
des atouts en France complètement
délirant intellectuellement et
médiatiquement et politiquement on est
très loin quand même de débat
raisonnable intellectuels sur ces points
là quoi
il y a une gauche dont on parle pas
c'est quand même la gauche dites de
gouvernement et celle-ci justement
qui de plus en plus de par cette
alliance électorale et cette bannière
Nupe
fourmille d'initiatives en dehors de la
nuque on le voit c'est par exemple
Carole Delga ou Bernard Cazeneuve donc
il y a aussi cette gauche là qui vit oh
les murs de la nuque et qui essayent de
bâtir quelque chose ou de porter un
discours
différente et compagnie ont clairement
choisi leur camp et ce n'est pas celui
de la gauche a dit Daniel balcon juste
puisque vous faites allusion à cette
gauche qui n'est pas du Pesse on va en
parler parce qu'il se trouve qu'il y en
a une gauche qui n'est pas du PS et elle
est ici elle siège ici notamment au
Sénat on va en parler avec Tam très nuit
qui nous rejoint
[Musique]
déjà parce qu'il n'y a aucun élu et les
filles au Sénat ça s'explique par la
faible implantation locale de la France
insoumise et par le scrutin sénatorial
qui est très particulier complètement
déconnecté de la présidentielle une fois
qu'on a dit ça au sein de la gauche
sanatoriale vous avez un peu 50 nuances
de nupes vous avez le groupe écologiste
qui se sent de plus en plus nupes
Guillaume Gontard le président du groupe
appartient la nuit Pesse il l'assume et
ça s'est vu lors du débat sur les
retraites où ils ont été les plus
offensifs dans l'obstruction vous avez
ensuite eh bien les communistes présidé
par Eliana Sassi pagne UPS du tout ils
revendique leur autonomie vis-à-vis de
la nuit pèse sur de nombreux sujets et
puis le plus grand groupe les
socialistes qui sont partagés vous avez
la moitié du groupe qui est trop fort et
donc proupès et l'autre moitié qui est
issu de la gauche hollandaise à l'image
de Patrick canner président du groupe ex
ministre de François Hollande et qui
entretient de relation tumultueuses
compliquée avec le premier secrétaire du
Parti socialiste et ça se voit dans sa
relation avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon avec
bien sûr le dernier épisode en date la
sortie de Jean-Luc Mélenchon de lundi
son appel à l'insurrection et son ABA la
mauvaise République pas du tout la tasse
de thé de Patrick canard je ne partage
pas du tout les propos de Jacques
Mélenchon qui est je dirais dans un
style bien connu moi je défends les
institutions de la République et je
défends surtout un ordre public qui
permet à chacun de s'exprimer dans de
bonnes conditions ce qui a été le cas
pour l'intersynical qui 14 fois
d'affilée a réussi à présenter un visage
uni mais surtout pacifique de sa
contestation voilà le TAC le reste poli
tout en modération sénatoriale mais
Patrick Kanner et de ceux qui n'ont pas
du tout apprécié le spectacle donné par
la gauche à l'Assemblée nationale lors
de la réforme des retraites avec les
invictives l'obstruction qui a empêché
d'aller jusqu'à l'article phare du texte
bref la stratégie insoumise
et la gauche sénatoriale elle a pourtant
aussi fait de l'obstruction aujourd'hui
pas d'un jour dans l'hémicycle une
stratégie concertée entre socialiste
communiste et écologiste l'occasion pour
la gauche sénatoriale de montrer elle
aussi un visage uni alors pas du tout
d'intergroupe encore comme il en existe
à l'Assemblée mais de nombreuses
réunions des conférences de presse
commune pendant le débat ensuite ils
sont encore allés tous ensemble plaider
devant le Conseil constitutionnel
plaider sur leur saisine unis dans le
combat contre les retraites donc quand
même depuis le mois de janvier mais on
commence déjà à avoir l'alliance ce
fissurer puisque par exemple les
communistes du Sénat ont déposé une
proposition de loi pour abroger la
réforme des retraites le hic et bien
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas de niche avant
l'été c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pas de
moments pour débattre de ce texte dont
ils sont à l'initiative dans l'hémicycle
en revanche les socialistes eux en ont
une c'est le 15 juin mais ils ont déjà
fermé la porte pour accueillir le texte
communiste ce qui donne l'impression
qu'une fois la bataille des retraites
terminées certains ont déjà envie de
reprendre leur bille merci beaucoup Tam
alors on parlait de divergence de fonds
là on le voit bien au Sénat tout le
monde n'est pas sur la ligne puis aussi
des divergences sur la stratégie
j'allais dire ou presque sur la tactique
parce que pour certains notamment les
socialistes et la gauche radicale ne
sera tout simplement jamais majoritaire
dans le pays donc il estime que c'est un
mauvais positionnement d'un purpoint du
tactique parce que ça sert à rien
défendre cette positionnement là si on
peut pas se faire élire notamment
secondaire présentiel écouter par
exemple ce qu'on disait un ancien
président François Hollande c'était hier
sur le quotidien ce qui est un problème
aujourd'hui dans la nuque c'est que
c'est elle ETI qui tient la ligne et que
cette ligne on peut la discuter on peut
on peut considérer que c'est trop ou pas
assez c'est plutôt trop mais c'est que
cette ligne ne permet pas d'arriver aux
responsabilités c'est-à-dire au pouvoir
il se trouve que j'ai été élu président
de la République j'ai été élu auprès de
la brique comme tous les présidents de
la République avec 50% des voix 50 il
faut le dire parce que il faut faire 50%
des voix au moins et ben pour ça il faut
être capable de rassembler d'élargir et
pas de se fixer sur une ligne qui est
assez minoritaire Frédéric savity il a
raison François Hollande je crois que
oui je suis désolé pierre
bon la gauche aujourd'hui c'est grosso
modo 25% à 26 27 au mieux dans les
scrutins alors il y a pas mal de gens
qui s'abstiennent il y a une partie des
classes populaires qui est partagée et
qui pourrait potentiellement sans doute
revenir vers vers un vote de gauche mais
en tout cas
les élections se succèdent et on les
voit très difficilement se remobiliser
on voit au contraire le rassemblement
national continuer à tracer son sillon
on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure donc et de
la dernière élection présidentielle on a
vu toujours une partie des lecteurs de
centre gauche appelant les comme ça mais
il se positionne eux au centre gauche
moi j'ai pas la définition de la gauche
qui continue à voter Emmanuel Macron dès
le premier tour en espérant ainsi faire
barrage et à Marine Le Pen et à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et les enquêtes montrent
effectivement que la personnalité de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon alors je sais pas si
c'est tous les éléments du programme je
pense qu'on exagère beaucoup la
radicalité du programme il y a un
déphases il y a un déphasage entre la
radicalité j'allais dire du style et la
radicalité des propositions mais bon
malheureusement on n'arrive pas à
distinguer les deux et très souvent
effectivement la radicalité du style est
utilisée pour stigmatiser des considérer
donc si on veut gagner avec son
présidentielle alors peut-être qu'il y
aura une élection législative anticipée
c'est pas exclu avant et à ce moment-là
les règles sont assez différentes mais
si l'objectif sélection présidentielle
est effectivement faut rassembler il
faut il faut passer le premier tour mais
il suffit pas de passer le premier tour
comme il faut aussi gagner et rassembler
50% derrière il est clair que il faut
s'adresser alors les gens de la nups à
LFI disent oui mais il y a les jeunes
qui s'abstiennent il y a les
abstentionnistes et bon malheureusement
on l'a vu dans les derniers scrutins
c'est pas c'est pas si simple il faut
50% plus voilà il faut 50% plus une voix
et on peut pas espérer une
surmobilisation voilà tel et aujourd'hui
malheureusement si on devait avoir un
candidat de la nuit Pesse
issu LFI face à Marine Le Pen au
deuxième tour rien ne laisse penser que
c'est le premier qui ou la première qui
l'emportera voilà la situation est là
donc quand Pierre organise un débat avec
la question c'est pas Bernard Cazeneuve
ou pas mais avec quelqu'un qui incarne
ou qui représente ou qui est issu je
pense qu'il faut qu'il y a tout pris un
dialogue là-dessus je pense que il y a
des raisons aujourd'hui
d'espérer que cette gauche que
représente François Hollande et on
pourrait quand même s'attendre un peu un
examen de conscience c'est-à-dire que
l'échec de 2012-2017 sert d'une
politique quand même de l'offre une
petite tournée vers les entreprises qui
a fait bon elle montre ses limites et
c'est pas des économistes de LFI qui le
disent c'est à toutes les enquêtes
montre effectivement qu'on a trop
privilégié on a trop attendu des baisses
d'impôts des
ça ne marchera pas uniquement en
dénonçant les
les vous n'êtes
pas
si c'est un moment comment va-t-on voter
pour vous si c'est pour refaire ce que
vous avez fait entre 2012 et 2017
vous avez prononcé son nom pour certains
autres électeurs de gauche c'est celui
que les insoumis appellent le boss de la
mupestres Jean-Luc Mélenchon il a encore
fait parler de lui cette semaine
Mathilde
oui on l'a vu la République c'est moi
donc c'est la nouvelle variante
c'est la façon on a connu la République
c'est moi et la variante qu'on a connu
qu'on a découverte cette semaine c'est à
bas la mauvaise République alors c'est
ce qu'il a déclaré en marge du 1er mai
une façon pour lui de faire parler de
lui une façon aussi de galvaniser ses
fans entre les lignes ça revient quand
même à appeler un renversement des
institutions et ça marche Mathieu
puisque ça a fait réagir on a vu Patrick
canner mais aussi jusqu'au sommet de
l'État on écoute Elisabeth borne
monsieur le Président vous évoquez
également les nouvelles outrances du
leader de la France insoumise elle
s'inscrivent dans une remise en cause
permanente de nos institutions elles
sont une nouvelle étape pour saper la
confiance de nos concitoyens dans notre
démocratie
ABA la mauvaise République dit-il chacun
le sait bien pour Jean-Luc mélencheux
Mélenchon la seule bonne République
c'est lui pour notre part nous sommes et
nous resterons du côté de la République
et de l'ordre républicain je vous
remercie
Emmanuel Macron lui aussi a réagi il a
cibler son opposant en ces termes les
factieux nourrissent les factions
c'était en conseil des ministres il
accuse aussi Jean-Luc Mélenchon de faire
la courte échelle au rassemblement
national alors Jean-Luc Mélenchon joue
régulièrement cette partie celle
d'établit en quelque sorte un parallèle
ou une suite logique entre
l'insoumission et cette insurrection
citoyenne à laquelle il appelle il
choisit cette stratégie de la tension et
du clivage permanent de la
conflictualisation pour tenter surtout
de rester en première ligne et de
reprendre les rênes de cette
contestation contre le gouvernement au
moment justement où le mouvement
syndical s'essouffle est-ce que c'est
forcément mauvais calcul d'un point de
vue politique alors il y a comme un
paradoxe chez Jean-Luc Mélenchon après
ce formidable coup politique dont on a
parlé celui de la de la Nupe l'année
dernière il sait presque immédiatement
replié sur une posture vindicative alors
au lieu de consolider ou de faire vivre
justement ce rassemblement de vouloir
peut-être quelque part se recentrer ou
de donner dégage à une gauche plus
raisonnable il donne plutôt des raisons
aux socialistes ou aux écologistes les
moins séduits par son style de vouloir
faire ces sessions alors résultat pas
grand monde ne croit au-delà des plus
fidèles insoumis à la capacité de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon de pouvoir ramener
cette gauche au pouvoir le trots ou
l'ancien trots se voit toujours comme le
leader maximo et plus il persiste dans
cette voie plus le front en continue
risque de proliférer et comme il a
quelques années d'expérience Mathieu et
qu'il est conscient des dégâts ou des
doutes qu'il peut citer dans son camp il
tend en permanence ce rapport de force
et on peut rappeler récemment ce tweet
d'adoublement assez étrange à François
Ruffin ou plutôt comme dirait certains
le baiser de la mort il avait twitté
François est prêt ça doit pas être vu
autrement de la part de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qu'une volonté finalement de
rester lui-même mettre des horloges et
de son destin et de garder le contrôle
merci Mathilde pierre jacuin est-ce
qu'il y a un un problème aujourd'hui que
Mélenchon est-ce que le grand fédérateur
est devenu aujourd'hui un obstacle je
pense en tout cas pour écouter les
membres de la nupestre que il est une
partie de la solution mais il est aussi
une partie du problème donc à un moment
donné il va falloir le résoudre Jean-Luc
Mélenchon dans les périodes hors
électorales il y a beaucoup de monde
pour le critiquer et quand il est en
campagne tout le monde s'aperçoit que
c'est en excellent candidat que les
sondages y déjoue les sondages qui
passent de 7 8 9 10 à presque 22% comme
c'était le cas en 2022 à la dernière
élection présidentielle je vais répondre
évidemment on poursuivant la question
mais je voulais revenir sur une chose
que vous avez dites parce que je trouve
très intéressant Mathilde vous avez dit
on n'a pas parlé de la gauche la gauche
gouvernementale jusqu'à maintenant et
c'est intéressant parce que la nuit
pêche c'est quoi justement c'est un
programme de gouvernement c'est un
accord de gouvernement donc ils ont dans
le débat politique on dit souvent il y a
la gauche gouvernementale non
gouvernementale comme si on disait que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et la France
insoumise n'était pas cette gauche
gouvernementale précisément il est cette
gauche gouvernementale je le disais moi
je participe même de ce discours
consiste à dire ce que Frédéric disait
tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire que le
programme de Jean-Luc Mélenchon est
spécial démocratique il y avait rien de
radical assis
quand on veut changer les institutions
quand on veut changer politique
c'est un programme social-démocrate pour
moi classique et ensuite sur les sujets
qui font que aujourd'hui on met Jean-Luc
Mélenchon sur la question de la méthode
comme étant un être radicale avec
notamment cette phrase qu'il a sorti sur
la mauvaise République j'ai écouté
évidemment ce que avec attention ce que
disait Patrick Kanner pardon mais là
aussi ils se sont mis d'accord au sein
de la nuit pèse sur un programme de
changement institutionnels je crois que
vous mettriez Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
Patrick canner là en face de l'autre
peut-être il dirait pas les choses dans
la même terme la question d'un
terminologie est importante entre nous
on peut s'entendre vivre la Sixième
République et par contre mais vous savez
ce que ça veut dire Jean-Luc Mélenchon
il est connu pour ça pour la 6e
République pour le changement des
institutions parce que la Cinquième
République il le dit très bien génère
des attitudes d'autoritaires comme on
les voit en ce moment et je vous dis
mettez Jean-Luc Mélenchon face à Patrick
kaner et je vous mets au défi de trouver
un des accords un des accords uniques
sur la question institutionnelle telle
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon la pose dans le
débat il y en aura aucun donc aussi un
artifice qui est un peu
désarçonnant pour les lectorat de gauche
et sympathisants de gauche de voir qu'il
y a des accords qu'on fait surgir alors
qu'en vrai il y a pas tant de désaccords
que ça à gauche Virginie Martin que doit
faire la nuit Pesse pour survivre à sa
première année déjà se mettre autour de
la table trouver une méthode
effectivement de collaboration ça c'est
important trouver aussi les plus petits
dénominateurs communs ça c'est vraiment
très important et se tenir bien sûr bien
sûr les quelques thèmes sur lesquels ça
ne bougera plus et ça c'est vraiment
important peut-être aussi évidemment
trouver assez rapidement quand même des
leaders à venir qui ont une stature
présidentiable ça ça me paraît
évidemment important parce que si c'est
encore Jean-Luc Mélenchon une énième
fois je pense qu'il y aura exactement
les mêmes effets et donc un échec à
terme donc ça ça me paraît important
aussi c'est pareil c'est la sixième
république là aujourd'hui maintenant
Olivier Faure si est résolu mais est-ce
qu'on peut pas aussi parler d'un
présidentialisme rationalisé une
cinquième république un peu plus modérée
si je puis dire et rationaliser plutôt
que que se basculement point
d'interrogation aussi donc il faut tout
de même quand même pierre là où je suis
un tout petit peu en désaccord c'est que
quand on a une attitude de partie
protestataire je parle bien d'attitude
et de fonctions tribunal à un moment
donné il faut savoir de toute façon ce
métamorphoser en partie le gouvernement
mais ça ça peut se faire presque un an
avant l'élection présidentielle pas la
peine mais de le faire bien sûr oui oui
enfin plus ou moins parce qu'il faut
quand même garder le leadership
médiatique et pour cela il faut quand
même toujours crier un peu plus fort
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre c'est
la fin de ce premier débat merci
Frédéric savity merci
Pierre Jacquemin